the drift two pilots melding memories
with the body of the machine going into
Mako's flashback was really a fun
opportunity because it's the only time
we ever spent any real time and really
see clearly one of these these memories
one of things I loved about that that
scene though is is it's all told
completely subjectively from from acos
point of view so she felt like the
monster was looking at her and coming
after her which may not have been really
what happened but that's how she
remembers it you know working from this
this idea of this memory being
subjective you know how does that
manifest itself and you know were the
first questions is well how big is this
monster so we kind of cheated the
monster to be a little larger than the
you know nominal 250 feet that we're
doing elsewhere in the film and I can't
quite fit into the roadway that that
were on and the monsters shouldering
through big buildings another important
aspect of the design of the sequence is
just visibility the ash wasn't
originally as dense as it was it was
kind of like a thin snow falling and we
ended up making that somewhat denser and
we want to wanted to make for a dramatic
reveal of the creature and she hides in
the alley and and she puts her hands
over her ears and then that you know the
sound goes goes muffled and and you just
catch these glimpses down the alleyway
were you it's massive battle going on
but you don't really see it happening
you just see the feet going back and
forth and cars flying and all of this is
happening off camera and seeing the
finished product on something that
you've worked on so intimately it's it's
an odd experience on one hand it's
really wonderful and exciting to see it
with final sound mix and music and color
times and everything together that's
great because it just of elevates
everything a bit on the other hand I've
seen every shot a thousand times we've
had long discussions of other things
that are working and aren't working and
and what the compromises were that I
made to make that work and and take me a
little while to kind of develop some
emotional distance from I found that it
usually takes about four or five years
but five years later I can look at
something and be a lot more objective
you know and just not not have that big
flood of memories and just kind of like
enjoy the film for what it is